you definitely do not pull women you
definitely do not have sex with women
your game is dead
dms
dating apps i don't have time for that i
don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe in
grilling them i'm going to be going on a
series of dates to find who can really
wow me
this is grilling
this is the comedian
um
sex chocolate of the year 2014. i'm a
single father and i need
someone to look after my kids to be fair
[ __ ] and the babysitter i expect [ __ ]
on the first date because i spent money
so that's my that's the only
expectations i have [ __ ] then we take
it from there i said do you want a
relationship is that what you're looking
for something long term
where's this what this is about i
thought it's all about getting [ __ ] on
the grill
hi hi
i'm good thank you wonderful you're
right
are you all right yeah okay what's your
name lisa there's a cheyenne oh i'm
joking
i will really bust in this girl's face
do i smell nice i don't know don't rate
this guy the way it looks sorry no
because of this date i i got a magazine
that i had from the train for about
about a year ago yeah and i had like a
scratch and sniff aftershave and i and i
used that today for you scratch and
sniff yeah well
hi
nice to meet you
did you have an okay journey getting
here it was it was a okay journey okay
so what about you yeah good nice okay
thank you
so
tell me about you how old are you what
do you do not tell me about you because
i've seen the program and i've seen like
you've been
ice skating kissing a lot of frogs so
how come you haven't gotten and you
ain't got
none of these guys that you've been
grilling i'm not really feeling it like
i know what i want what do you want i
want a man that's assertive there's very
alpha
that knows how to look after a woman but
not controllable women give time and
love and affection you know i think that
she's out there to get battered you will
find that that's not you then like
you've been watching a lot of love
romantic movies like do you like them
romantic movies yeah do you think i'm
living in the family yeah man you need
to come out of the hollywood
relationship and what and get into the
the kidnapping relationship what's that
real world okay well what's that then
that means it's like a man's gonna take
you out you are beautiful
thank you but just allow me in it don't
allow you why are you don't don't ask me
where i might be like oh what how comes
i didn't call you today or oh you saw
two blue ticks and no reply but this is
what i'm saying communication is key and
that's that's already a red flag just so
you know you used to don't have a lot of
reflections okay what's that then dating
a lot of guys and not being with none of
them but i'm not sleeping with them so i
could do what i want i can actually do
what i want in my like free time it's
all right yes you know yes you can like
when you're dating like atlanta for me
like i'm dating with intention
so i'm not just going to go around and
sleep with everyone i want to make sure
like i'm making the right choice i don't
want to just make a decision just
because i like your vibe like it has to
be right so that's why i'm dating
multiple people it may seem i'm not
saying she's a whole but she's wholish
i've got kids have you i'm an older guy
oh cute family man i'm liking it
what's your relationship like would you
have a toxic baby mom is it not i live
with my kids
because i want to because are you still
with a baby no i'm not with the big one
but you live together yeah no i don't
live together wait did you live with
your kids or not see that's something to
say you're stereotyping me no i'm not
i'm asking you a man because he can't
because he's got his kids it must be um
some social service was involved or a
toxic baby why can't i just want my kids
i didn't say social stuff that come out
of your mind
you're thinking i'll say yeah
that's you problem that's your only
insecurity that you're projecting on to
me so i don't have insecurities baby
okay tell me about you then diesel i've
just told you about me think of your
kids yeah and that's it and i do comedy
yeah
i'm here trying to find a nice
wife slash babysitter what do you mean
babysitter
babysitter
it's alarming that you would let
somebody that you're only just dating
like look after your kids because you
want a babysitter i didn't say if i
hired a babysitter then where do i know
where from
i don't know she probably got daddy
before she come to my house i must deny
myself pom-pom because of them yeah
that's disgusting you'd actually choose
a woman of your kids yeah pump them up
yes i feel like you're dating for all
the wrong reasons
what are you dating for because you've
been i'm knowing for love no but you're
not because you've i've seen that you
had a lot of lovely guys here and you
you've just been so horrible so you
think that all those guys are really
lovely i'm just saying out of all them
frogs you couldn't find your prince
charming no
that's a song about you
for a person that flows up red flags i'm
throwing up a lot of red cards to you
okay which are there's something about
you that you're not saying like what i
don't know i think you might have a past
i need you to be honest with me how many
men have you been been with in your
whole lifetime in my whole lifetime i
couldn't tell y'all to be honest that's
what i'm trying to say right what's
wrong with that you don't know how much
money you sleep with i like that you
know sometimes i said five or you know
low but because your number so high you
don't even know how much i rate that
it's a really high i've set with
thousands of men
that's the conversation you have to have
with your vagina that's not i don't i
can't get involved in that desperately
you say vagina
i've abused it throughout the years but
we won't make it
girl sorry
i'm the panani whisperer
her [ __ ] was talking to me it was
saying helps
help
so how many people have you slept with
i'm like you
you like me
i don't know my body count but i don't
know man as in like i'm not counting but
i'm not out here moving mad in that
sense well that sounds mad no it's
because i'm not kidding i'm not moving
no majorities they're so bad like my
dating experience have been so bad i
just like blocked them out like it
didn't happen when it's that tragic
sorry it doesn't count i know i feel
like it's hard for you for you girls
dating guys it is isn't it it is
and i put it down to the video fixings
because we could get pom-pom
so quick and easy can you though because
i feel like men that say that a lot
really don't get [ __ ] i don't believe
that that you're not
in last night that's what you did in
here i didn't say i was i wanted to be
with the person i was just
you want those guys that have
meaningless sex
yeah
sex sexy sex i could as long as i bust
in something versus my hand on your
chest in your condom in your hair
it was great sex to me
how many times have i got to explain
this
do you think i look nice yeah because i
would have got from a long time what do
you mean do you know how i came to come
here i'm gonna come sit down there for
no
dead things that's rude but you're not
dead so it's not rude yeah but if i was
then i'd be gone no write yourself out
of ten then what do you think you are to
be getting up and doing that i was at 60
the other day but i've been going gym
and i'm even funnier so i'm about 11.
take away five
you can stay as the six but i got a big
dick so that makes up that's about 15.
big dick don't mean nothing it
you know your makeup's running down your
face like a horror movie then you know
that stuff
is worth i like when
my dick's in your mouth and i look down
it looks like i got a vagina because i
don't see nothing
that's girth
girth is worth
why is he talking like that you've got a
pretty fraught i don't know why are you
looking at my phone because
long story
he is so
weird have you ever adam's apple before
no
would you like one
what do you mean
you don't know what happens
yeah
i'm a female so how am i going to get
one
use imagination i don't have one
red flag
why
there we go what is it you want me to
imagine
a troll
why would i do that
because you want to see the adam's apple
in it
this is what happens when you don't have
sex ladies and gentlemen
all right then do you sucked it
no
i thought i'd say i'm going on i don't
need to leave here then do you [ __ ] no
no you can leave it as well then
i think we're made for each other
do you think
i think it'll be really awful they all
say they don't need fussing he
definitely does you're a pessimist
why because you don't see the optimism
of our date right because you've just
asked me to imagine you're
in my throat so do you have sex on the
first date
know it with the england lost [ __ ]
world cup that's how devastated that'd
be if i didn't have sticks on the first
date you said that if you went on a
first date and didn't get pumping it
would feel like oh god please don't say
that's like
that's like a horrible word nope
england
losing us please
what's your techniques to pull a woman
i just make her laugh i laugh off her
panty
then to be fair you could banter me into
bed if you were funny but you're not so
i'm i'm serious like a judge right now
okay
what's your type you
no what is your actual type no you can't
do that that's like the worst
way to explain you're just trying to rub
me out here i'm trying to give you the
most compliments you're my type it's a
nice smooth neck
sorry
why does he keep looking at my throat
for like i thought
it's making me feel weird stop looking
at my throat
would you like lie to have sex i feel
like you would you're the type can i say
something to you
no if it's about my neck you can't
i don't say anything then yeah i don't
but every man likes to get pom-pom
[ __ ] is designed to be lied to that's
the that's it was designed
it's got that it's got that size that's
why it's shaped like that
[ __ ] shaped like lies
so you tell it lies do you use being
funny as a defense mechanism no i use it
to get [ __ ] but i don't get [ __ ] i do
you're definitely not funny enough to
get person sorry
well at least i could get the troll
whose throat you ain't getting mine can
you be romantic obviously
it's not obvious what's the most
romantic thing you've done being here
sitting on a date with you in this nice
beautiful place that's you romantic yes
you're romantic if i was going to be
romantic i would take you out to my
virgin center place yeah
get your nice jerk yeah get your nice
jerk with some rice and peas it's a
biggest punch
pineapple punch small some herbs
and let's chill out
the silence says enough
are you in touch with your emotions yes
i do
yes you do
i guess they happen you are yeah you
keep passing everything off as a joke
and you're really not you know and
that's that's okay yeah yeah you know
that's that and that's your opinion
and that's okay that's what i'm
witnessing no no that's that's your
opinion and that's okay to me
do you think it's important that men cry
i like crying yeah
a girl was giving me a head one time i
was crying stop referring everything
back to sex
that's the time i was crying when the
girls gave me that
i don't know if it was a teeth but i was
emotional why does everything keep going
back to sex it's like this full circle
and then sex
so you've got sons i'm asking you yeah
because this is a serious question like
how you raise the next generation yes is
it important for men to be in tune with
their emotions you sound like you want
to [ __ ] all no
so if your son cries you're going to
call him a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
how is he going to say as a family man
and call his child a [ __ ] for crying
give me a scenario i don't know
something's hurt him he falls over he
hurts himself how are you dealing with
it
get up put someone come at my face i'll
stop the crying i'll give you something
to cry about fly kick in your back piece
of [ __ ]
that's how i deal with it
with toxic masculinity and things like
that you have to be able to nurture
emotions and stuff okay so you end up a
bit like you and having the defense
mechanism making everything a joke when
it's not
can i see your phone and where's your
dms please
are you do you know how incriminating
that would be for my life are you stupid
well i'm not telling no one it's like
you'd ask to finger me in my battery
hole in front of 40 000 people
that's the equivalent of asking me for
my phone right now what would you let me
see it though
after you've deleted everything no but
the batch is dead that's the only time
you can see my phone do you think she's
gonna be looking through my phone not a
blood clot really 110
but if it's just work on there if i've
asked you to pay the bills for me then
that's different are you that guy that
has like two phones listen we're trying
to protect your feelers if you see you
in my phone you probably get into
depression and i'm trying to stop you
from doing that so what are you doing to
make me depressed
i can't see what's on your phone
what's your favorite sex position or
move it's called the quadrophenia what's
that i'll get your legs i put it around
that leg and then i get the other leg
put it around your waist so your pump
pumps open like this like this thing
with um and i actually put a candle on
top of the pom-pom
and i frost
and the candles go
it looks romantic
do you want to try it no as i mentioned
why you got a candle on top of your
pom-pom no
i'm going to show you i'm going to give
some experience okay you're not okay
because you haven't had the candle in
the wind
that's what it's called
really don't feel no chemistry i don't
even feel chemistry i want you to feel
my hood in your hole
what is he doing
i'm just gonna give you some good if
you're the scientist for chemistry you
go to the science museum
i'm getting your whole yes sir i don't
deal with chemistry i deal with beet
history
after even reading the word
this is what i'm saying going back to
like this meaning the sex thing like
it's not meaningless because i'm gonna
bust you're gonna bust how's that
meaningless i'm not on that i just i
just don't like the way
people just date these days like can i
say something to you i could sit here
and be the best version of how you want
me to be
and the we could go out we could do the
most
glorious stuff but if i get in the
bedroom and i and your pump on big like
narnia we've got a problem i don't care
how good you are your [ __ ] big so i
need to eliminate that i don't waste my
time on months dating you and then when
i gain your
pom-pom i can't i'm i'm they're
searching and finding them with light as
i'm finding remotes in your pom-pom let
me know now in it as a jamaican say we
know what i'm buy puss in our bag calm
down like just calm down why is why is
he so hyped do you have you spent
somebody before why'd you like to be
spanked do you think i need a spankings
i've been a lonely boy you've been a
prick that's what you've been oh you
want bricks see you got this you can't
get dicks off your mind in it i bet she
lives in [ __ ] foster isn't it she just
wants to be around cox
come out of the gutter
you definitely do not pull women you
definitely do not have sex with women
your game is dead
you're fascinated about my dick you are
could you no that's your imagination not
mine
i see you you're looking like babe it's
all right it's a right to be a whole
sometimes i know sometimes you're
probably around friends i think you know
what it's not okay but i can see in your
eyes you've got them wholish eyes
eyes
i'm not saying you're hope but you're
wholish
i've got whole way vision
yeah
i see it
look i know he needs to see but those
glasses
come on why are you wearing those
glasses
looking purposes and i can see your
whole eyes more better do you wear them
when you're having sex they're turning
me on you want to have sex with me
look i'll wear a fireman's suit i'll
wear the glasses
which way is the way out
what do you want me to wear for but do
you it's a genuine question or do you
have to take them off
i want to see one when i'm when i'm
having sex
yeah
no
listen
i'm from a
strong jamaican family from the hood
i've got street credibility
i don't know who rates you but okay this
is no one yes but it has to be on the
weekend so you do then
weekends so yeah so you want to stop the
card no because
if i done in the weekday then i'd be a
bald cat but because i do on the
weekends
i don't really qualify to be a bobcat so
i can't say that you are a bokeh i'm not
because i do weekends
now
no
would you not see this i'm saying you're
[ __ ] some of your exes in there never
never never no no don't no
because you just been chatting [ __ ] all
day
i've been real to you have you heard
yourself have you heard yourself trying
to be i'm gonna miss
why is he so angry
no
why not why the [ __ ] what's wrong with
you
colombo i wouldn't even go for your
phone it's just nice to know that's
something you want to know you're too
knowing
yeah
you want to know everything allow it
yeah i do but when it's a relationship
you're meant to be a partnership
so yeah not that i'm gonna go for i'm
not gonna say it's not that i want to do
whatever you want my number four you
don't want to go for it oh i want to buy
condoms
it's for the security just knowing it's
the security just in case you're taking
the piss out of me you're taking the
piss out yourself
yes and no no so you're a loyal person i
just can't go through your phone of
course i'm gonna like not have a bitch's
front pictures and i've got you that's
nice
i've got a nice side to me you know yeah
are you loyal yes i am loyal i've got
one barber
that's it you're loyal to your barber
not your woman well there's something
different something in it
i have to stand for [ __ ] something
what do you want from me loyal to my
woman and my brother too much today
right now that's too much that's too
much stress let me just be loyal to one
my baba at least then i could
probably one day move on to my
girlfriend
you know what i'm going to say no as
well now you're taking the piss out of
me
i'm not
you know that you like a form or two up
in your backyard
please just please please put me on my
music please i'm gonna please i'm in the
name of jesus please i'm up please
have you had your back doors kicked off
yes or no
i'm not gonna answer that she's like oh
okay
holy [ __ ]
did you just call me houston yes
well they answered mine
you lying
you're a liar
what is this obsession with ho and
harisha no we're not there to do these
little nicknames like we're not on that
level no i am the pom-pom whisperer
i know hoes from 17 miles away i could
have my eyes closed i think
there's a hole in there
that's how good i am
i'm a whole detective
yes yeah do you
i've got food i could cook crap i got my
cooker you say you cooked crack you
asked can i cook in a cup it needs to be
cooked i'm just saying i've cooked
that's one of the dishes like a cook it
all makes sense now i'm connecting the
dots now everything is starting to make
sense
do you pay i'll pay babes
of course i will
but then do you expect sex
and i didn't want to have sex how how
how do we do this you see a county
called county court judgment gave your
door for my money that i spent that
[ __ ] night before i want back every
penny i'm taking it to court i'll send
bailiffs to your [ __ ] yeah you broke
what is brock you can be broke there's
two different kinds of brokers yeah i
think there's a break where when you're
hustling and you're going for a struggle
to get there that broke's okay but if
you're just a bum and broke that's the
problem and the two of them you're broke
just say i don't like putting labels on
having no money
have you got money live comfortably
there we go so you can look after me
while i get back on my feet have you
ever sent a pom-pom selfie
i've sent pictures to boyfriend
she's also a boyfriend i know
i
i knew it
and it was like
nice people i connected
we didn't connect
oh i'm a hoe now so you're asking now
i'm at home if you're not a whole you're
hobbyish
are you an essex girl i am so you look
like that girl shut up you look like one
of those types
i don't sound like that because you're
trying to be posh you're not [ __ ] i'm
trying to be poor you're trying to be
positive this is just how i speak that's
not how you speak it's not
okay
she could be on geordie shore even she
just looks like that proper tv reality
star that gets
on camera in the room and it's in the
papers and she's got a boyfriend she
looks like one of those girls what would
you do if i wanted to involve other
people in our sex life has to be [ __ ]
why what kind of
what if i wanted other man
then no
no no no why that's that's i'm trying to
stop you from being this horizon that
you that you so solely want to be why
hold on so how does it make me hope so
you want to have other women involved
yeah but i can't have other men because
it would make me at home obviously this
is also then she likes too much men in
her sex life so i'm trying to be that
guy to take her away from that life
because she is about that life so i'm
trying to i'm trying to i'm trying to
smooth down the holes
you understand i'm trying to be that guy
for her
one dick to happen yay one dick two upon
10 girls a day
i'm class i get a medal i get like
i go to the club man like me high fiving
you got 10 men right now you be hoisha
why why is that i didn't make the rules
don't but you're going up i hate the
player baby hate the game but you're
going along with them you could just be
like actually
double standards it's not double
standards you are a heart
not you but if you do
i like her but i just wanted to be real
i don't know if i like or hate you it's
like this friend you like love really
you actually love me the guys that's
been on there there's been you know
humor in you flattering you you need
somebody real that's going to tell you
about your blood clot itself do you
think you're humbling me i'm humbling
your [ __ ] clap sorry i'm not sorry i
went into jamaican mug so
yes i'm humbling your ass i don't think
you are
i'm laughing like at you not with you
just you know what would you do if your
friends are liking up all my pictures
online so all my friends are sliding
their dms i want that happening what
yeah i do normally want to be no butters
if i if
i feel like if you're waiting
realistically let's be real for a minute
as much as you're saying you don't want
someone that's like not as hot but if
you ran out of a woman that was really
attractive your ego wouldn't handle the
way men approach an attraction why not
that's what i call what happens it
happens and then you start moving mad
then you get jealous and it's like oh
why was he smiling at you like that why
was he looking genuine
sorry it happens i know why you're
judging me let me tell you this i always
work with tens not because you're a
seven and a half i always quit tense
you're the lowest i've been to be fair
this guy is definitely over exaggerating
on how much [ __ ] he gets
what would you do if i didn't want to
sleep with you for the first six months
of our relationship if i genuinely liked
you
then i wouldn't make you sleep with me
for the first six months i would i would
roll with it would you yes i see you
don't just do meaningless sex
i mean you can have a girl see already
well that's like that's possible
but i would i wouldn't pressure you for
sex because i'd be but i'd be getting
sex
i just want to get sex from you what
would you do if i'd slept with two of
your friends in the past
i wouldn't mind but if you gave them
head then
it's long why
because i don't be tasting my friend's
dick in their mouth you're not going to
taste you're going to taste it no you're
not subconsciously i'm going to be
thinking about it
i want to be having sex i'm thinking
does my mouth taste like my friend's
dick
that's just too much information to
handle i want to be
not thinking
does your mouth smell like my friends
did if you didn't give them a head i'll
still but if you gave him ahead i mean
okay
what would you do if my ex was after you
if you had good [ __ ] then i would
forgive him but if he's dead [ __ ] no
but we're in beef
how can you [ __ ] beef me for some big
hole gal
you're rude
i'm not gonna beef you for that
i'm not gonna beat you for that you can
keep that big gigantic new new normous
this is a new word new enormous
you're really rude about women
sue me i don't like girls with big holes
surely if every woman has a big vagina
your dick is not big and that's actually
a compliment because when a woman is
more comfortable and relaxed she's more
wetter so is that oh my god see you're
just trying to make stories for your big
phone now oh you're just just trying to
make a whole story
oh that's what you're doing here is that
what we're doing here telling me
i just like you no
it's like wireless four tenths
is this what you wear to dates by the
way it's not so that's what you wear so
that i'm all dressed up for what reason
you're supposed to be you're supposed to
impress me you're also supposed to
impress me
i could just say something by the way
you didn't just you know so i knew see
great a man that knows the thing
he knew not to dress up because he knew
that he was going to be hit sitting
there changing [ __ ] to me i'd even bathe
before i come
you what i didn't even have a shower
before i come so can you i'm i'm gonna
be totally honest like we've been honest
if you wanted to give me a head now i
would say no
unless you're like cheese he fully just
said his dick stinks
so how do you think you've done on a
date today if you don't give me [ __ ]
or even give me a second date
you're a [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ] so it's
not on you that you're that's not me
it's not on me because i've given the
realness
i could have as i said i could have came
here and played the game
but i just wanted to see the realness
date went well
i loved it can't wait to do another one
if she wants to come back with me
this day was awful
if she's real to herself i'm not trying
to hide her horizon-ness
then we'll do this
i'm definitely not dating this guy again
she'll take her wholeness to the grave i
like a loyal hole like that
no surprises just a big disappointment
she's she's brilliant to be fair my
advice is calm down stop sexualizing me
and stop looking at my throat well i
rate myself as a 10 underweight but i
would rate this day it feels a 10
25 my jenna
25 out of 10 that makes as much sense as
me and him together i grilled her
because i'm a griller i dealt with her
like a piece of style on steak you
understand she dealt with me like she's
trying to put two shrimps on the barbie
i'm not no shrimp listen this guy
doesn't even deserve to be on that
scoreboard you know so i'm gonna give
him
a
two
[Music]
you